[Music]
the body of farook Salama is carried
through the streets of Janine in the
north of the occupied West Bank reported
to be a prominent commander of the Armed
Islamic Jihad group he died when Israeli
forces raided a refugee camp the group
is calling it a cowardly assassination
the reaction of the resistance will be
gut willing inside Israeli cities
however our main AIM now in Janine Camp
is to protect our people land and Camp
the health Ministry says a 14 year old
boy was also killed their deaths come as
more than 30 diplomats visited nebulus
and as Israeli forces lifted a
three-week Siege of that City
this occupation is fleeting like the
rest of the occupations throughout
history and the second message is that
Collective punishment cannot continue
further south in the village of Beitel
more Devastation for Palestinian
families
shot dead by Israeli forces who say he
threw a fire bomb towards them
the occupation Army invaded the village
with combat units where it had already
decided to kill the young men confronted
them
City police blocked off streets as blood
was washed from the ground Israeli
forces shot dead Palestinian near the
Al-Aqsa mosque after they accused him of
stabbing a soldier
professional indetermined action to
neutralize the terrorists and most
likely prevented injury to innocent
civilians we will continue to be in the
same Readiness with the same alert of
the police officers for every event
it comes following Israel's general
election that seen the far right gain
more power
this year more than 130 Palestinians
have been killed as Israel intensifies
raids it says it's combating militants
Palestinians say it's an attempt to
crush uprisings
law Robert Manley Al Jazeera